my proudest achievements of my children
I mean that very sincerely I think for a
parent the most important thing is
preparing the next generation of helping
to prepare the next generation I'll be
very honest with you I think that a lot
of the public work I've done in my
nonfiction it's been a failure that is I
had and I had a goal in a lot of my
writing to try to nudge conversation a
little bit closer to a Norman which we
actually saw cross our differences a
common beloved humanity in those with
whom we have strong disagreements that's
in my goal in different ways whatever
running about religion and politics or
civility in public life or a lot of the
other books I've written that's been my
general goal and all I've seen to my
despair is that getting worse instead of
better that day by day week by week
month by month year by year it's simply
getting worse and so in that sense I
don't at the moment feel terribly
optimistic about our politics I hope for
the best I pray for the best I still
sometimes work for the best but I feel
that the mission I felt I was on at one
point is a mission that did not succeed
and I think really didn't make much of a
difference
hey